la nouveau président forcément peut voir
des choses différemment
je sais que j'en ai assez attachés à
cette ce rapprochement
mais les difficultés que l'épidémie a
suscité dans nos économies locales et
c'est peut-être donner d'autres
priorités aujourd'hui ce qui est certain
c'est que georges siffredi et moi même
sommes dans l'état d'esprit de gens qui
veulent approfondir la coopération entre
ces deux départements parce qu'elle est
de notre point de vue est essentielle
pour l'ouest parisien et plus
globalement d'ailleurs pour la région
parisienne
la france ça veut dire que le travail a
peut-être des gens qui le rend très vite
sur survenait normalement nous voyons
vendredi avec genre qui a été élu hier
d'envoyer confère pas de tendre une
longue réunion de travail pour faire le
point sur tous nos dossiers et dossier
passer les dossiers présents et à venir